I think we spoke last time about a year
ago how is your view on um Benjamin
Netanyahu evolve over time Benjamin
Netanyahu has committed himself to the
Eraser of Palestinian people and
Palestinian symbols and Palestinian Land
from the very beginning of his political
career this is who he has been
we just haven't been listening to him he
campaigned on bigotry and racism and on
the promise that there would never be a
Palestinian State he campaigned on the
promise that Gaza would be wiped out he
campaigned by saying the Arabs are
rushing to the poles we need to make
sure that they don't infect our policy
he has always been this person this has
always been his policy he has always
indicated that genocide and ethnic
cleansing is is where he wants to go so
uh he's simply manifesting what his
message has always been and anyone that
ignores that is being disingenuous you
can find statements from Benjamin
Netanyahu in the 80s 90s 2000s you can
find him talking about this prior to
October 7th and after October 7th he's
definitely doing this now to save his
political career I think he wants to
drive this as long as he possibly can
because he knows that his days in office
are numbered but let's also ask
ourselves why is it that Benjamin
Netanyahu was able to rise to power in
the first place right there is something
deeply troubling about the fact that his
messaging ever resonated and what the
prospects are uh for for peace if
Benjamin Netanyahu is able to rise with
such pronounced hateful
messaging so the claim that security of
Israel is the primary concern is you're
saying a um dishonest claim I think he's
trying to secure his seat in office he
knows his days are numbered this is not
about Israel this isn't about the
hostages for him this isn't about
anything but Benjamin Netanyahu he is a
narcissist he's a tyrant um he is
despised uh around the world and uh I
think even amongst Israelis uh I think
there's a deatri for him I think the
hostages families know that he doesn't
care about about the families or about
the hostages but he's driving a
political agenda that doesn't care about
people um not Palestinian people or
otherwise
however the problem of the occupation is
not Benjamin Netanyahu the problem of
the occupation is the occupation uh y
leid was uh the progressive moderate
alternative and uh he drove just as
bigoted of an agenda against the
Palestinian people as possible so to the
Palestinian that's living in in Gaza or
the Palestinian in the West Bank whoever
is sitting in that seat has meant the
exact same thing to them but Benjamin
Netanyahu is certainly I think the
loudest bigot that we have seen um you
know in that
seat